pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
prévu à grand spectacle pour les
athlètes du monde entier une revue qui a
lieu tous les quatre ans qui est digne
des meilleures productions
hollywoodiennes
un flambeau passé de mains en mains
depuis athènes un stade immense où se
pressent 90000 spectateurs pour assister
à la grande parade ouverte par la
délégation grecque
c'est ainsi que débute à rome les dix
septièmes jeux olympiques durant
plusieurs heures aux délégations
succèdent les délégations il y en a 85
venant de toutes les parties du monde
britanniques et irlandais se présente
devant la tribune officielle les
athlètes n'ont pas encore troqué la jupe
ou le pantalon pour la tenue de
compétitions et reshma dans la
délégation britannique
[Applaudissements]
très traditionaliste chez des
pakistanais fidèle au turban
[Musique]
50 étoiles sur un drapeau tricolore
canotiers à la maurice chevalier
tel se présente les athlètes des états
unis qui précède les soviétiques
gracieuse et souriante garçons sévère et
discipline est prêt à donner le meilleur
d'eux mêmes pour faire triompher les
couleurs de leur pays
point final à cette cérémonie
d'ouverture l'arrivée de la flamme
olympique
[Musique]
symboliquement jusqu'à la fin des jeux
cette flamme ne cessera de brûler la
grande revue est close maintenant place
au sport
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'une des plus belles épreuves de ces
jeux le 100 m nage libre
les espoirs américains reposent sur
larsson ceux des australiens sur john de
witte larsson est de vite dans l'ordre
occupent les deux lignes au centre de la
piscine il n'arrive pas à se dégager au
50 m haies 8 nageurs vivent ensemble
avec un léger avantage cependant brésil
hier dawson ce sprint extraordinaire
jusqu'à l'ultime seconde tous les
spectateurs du stade nautique sont tenus
en haleine larsson n'arrive pas à
décrocher de vip qui de son côté ne peut
pas prendre un point d'avancé sur son
rival de santos le troisième larron va
peut-être les mettre d'accord
une gerbe d'écumé trois hommes dans un
mouchoir qui a gagné il fallait bien un
vainqueur c'est donc l'australien qui
remporte la médaille d'or larsson et
second dans le même temps que deux
vitres
quant à dos santos il reçoit la médaille
de bronze
[Applaudissements]
entre course à suspense le 200 m brasse
féminin dans la dernière longueur de
bassin
c'est un coude à coude impressionnante
la britannique annie talos bron et
l'allemande ville fraude ou mme seidman
ces deux jeunes filles mettent autant
d'énergie que les garçons pour triompher
elle force
l'une et l'autre jusqu'à l'épuisement un
italien mauro un style plus efficace que
l'allemande elle se dégage très
légèrement dans les derniers mètres et
rapport classique et la médaille
olympique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh les spectateurs vont avoir besoin
maintenant d'un peu de détente cette
détente ce sont les plongeuses qui leur
fournissent les américaines sont sans
concurrent du mois le croit-elle ici un
très joli plongeant de mademoiselle
williams l'une des favorites de
l'épreuve un pic
[Applaudissements]
c'est autour de la britannique ferris
tout aussi à l'aise que sa rivale a
l'impression que ces championnes ne font
aucun effort
l'américaine numéro un bis pop ne se
doute pas encore quelle sera battu par
une toute jeune allemande
en attendant effectué une remarquable
figure pas d'assez bonnes cependant pour
être mieux cotés que mademoiselle kramer
la petite allemande que voici
et qui s'attribue le titre olympique
[Musique]
l'achète et écureuils ont fait connaître
par la voix de monsieur gas and co de
l'académie des sciences de l'urss leurs
impressions deux premiers êtres
terrestre revenu sur terre après en
avoir fait 18 fois le tour à quelques
320 km d'altitude en même temps qu'elle
des souris des mouches des germes de blé
des bactéries attenté à leurs
témoignages sur les possibilités du
voyage de l'homme dans l'espace
la bonne santé des deux petites chaînes
affirme que cette éventualité n'est plus
très loin
dakar a vécu des heures de fièvre le
sénégal s'est retiré de la fédération du
mali à l'assemblée législative les
parlementaires ont proclamé
l'indépendance du sénégal au cours d'une
séance historique où léopold senghor
avait fixé la position de son pays
et soudain l'air et v selon leur
tempérament d'un état unitaire ou chez
nous on est dominé grâce à leur l'ombre
et à leur discipline
nous voulions nous donnait pas fédérale
créée sous il rêvait de concentré
l'essentiel des pouvoirs fédéraux entre
les mains d'un seul homme voulions d'un
régime démocratique où les pouvoirs pour
collaborer se partageraient et
s'équilibre la foule s'est rangé
derrière ces leaders nationaux depuis le
général de gaulle président de la
communauté a proposé ses bons offices
aux deux états indépendants et le fossé
qui les sépare est profond
la tension mondiale demeure fixé sur le
congo où la conférence interafricaine
organisé par monsieur lumumba a tenu ses
assises en dépit de la défection des
chefs d'état et celle même de cinq
nations sur les vingt invités l'arrivée
des délégués au palais de la culture à
léopoldville a donné lieu à une
manifestation organisée contre monsieur
le moomba par le parti de la bac
le service d'ordre composé de soldats et
de policiers a réagi avec brutalité pour
disperser les manifestants qui au nombre
d'un millier vitupéré le chef du
gouvernement
c'est à coups de crosse que la place a
été dégagée ces mêmes policiers devaient
par la suite s'en prendre aux
journalistes et reporters dont plusieurs
ont été frappés
la bagarre n'en est pas resté là et les
forces de police ont tiré mais à blanc
précise le gouvernement lumumba réduite
en nombre et en qualité
la conférence si elle soutient lumumba
dans le principe de l'unité congolaise
ne semble pas envisager la fourniture de
troupes pour réduire le katanga au delà
du fleuve kasaï qui donne son nom à une
province dont une partie est entrée en
récession les tribunes loi et baluba se
livrent une guerre sans merci les
troupes envoyées pour y rétablir l'ordre
ont trouvé sur leur route des villages
incendiés des populations en fuite et
des cadavres calcinés
douloureux contrepoint de ce drame la
belgique a rendu hommage à ceux de ses
morts dont les restes lui arrive anvers
une émouvante cérémonie a uni le roi et
le peuple belge devant 49 cercueil ceux
de soldats morts au cours de ce qu'on a
pu appeler les vêpres congolaise
[Musique]
au large de brest sur le porte avions
clemenceau série d'essais de décollage
et davantage lancée en décembre 1957 le
premier des porte avions construit par
la france depuis la guerre est entrée
dans sa période de service actif lorsque
les intercepteurs d'assaut étendard
quatre seront joints auprès des alizés
et osac ils ont déjà embarqué
il comptera 60 appareils à son bord
avec ces cas pas pu la vapeur sa piste
oblique avec son miroir d'appontage
remplaçant le classique batman le
clemenceau qui jauge 27 mille tonnes est
une unité ultramoderne
on entend de prendre sa place dans la
flaque il peut être considéré comme l'un
des meilleurs gages de la vitalité de la
marine française
[Musique]
oh
voici révélé la nouvelle ligne que dior
à préparer pour la rentrée prochaine
une rentrée qui nous ramène curieusement
quelques 35 ans en arrière
éternel retour de la mode qui a l'air de
nous plonger au plus beau temps de 1925
on retiendra seulement cette définition
la robe ne porte plus la femme mais le
corps prend vie sous la robe qui devient
une espèce développent plus vite et
dansant
la même liberté s'impose aux manteaux
dont les caractéristiques sont de
posséder de l'argent bien sûr et souvent
de longues fendues sur les côtés
[Musique]
préférence pour le noir et les couleurs
foncées
quant aux robes du soir
elles répondent plus encore à la volonté
de créer une silhouette longue et
flexible
[Musique]
le buste est long l'âge est souple
telle est la mode de l'automne et de
l'hiver prochain les mauvais esprits
diront qu elle nous ramène à 1925 qu'on
n'en croit rien nous sommes bien et
l'élégance nous confirme en 1960
[Musique]